[Music]
okay hello we're starting thank you for
coming to the bring the cloud to your
session this morning you've ever been to
the keynote and heard about exciting and
those announcement so here we have a
panel after the product and engineering
leaders responsible for creating NGOs to
answer the question any questions you
might have
first we're going to introduce ourselves
so here's rule for our panelists
everybody's gonna tell the audience your
name your role and your favorite song
that describes CSP and bonus points if
you're able to sing okay I can start my
name is Ray well I lead a product team
for identity config and policy
management for CSP my song is John
Lennon's Imagine imagine out-of-work
clothes living life in peace okay start
from great my name is Alberto maestra
I'm a manager at Google and my son is
don't stop believing by journey given
that we're all together in this journey
you didn't think a lot of customers hi
everybody I'm Shanna Goldberg I'm the
engineering director leading many of the
anthos engineering teams and my song is
think by Aretha Franklin like the
freedom huh and the reason why I know I
can sing it because I used the Google
home I sang it to it and then he told me
what's the song is hey my name is Jess
Leroy director of product management on
the security side let's see my song for
this was science heal delivered I want
super ultra cheesy because as the
security guy sign with certificates
sealed with GK security and delivered
through anthos so all right here I am
baby
signed sealed delivered I'm yours
[Applause]
my name is a pernessa now I think the
product team for kubernetes gke now
what's called what's part of anthos GK
on-prem and GK migrate or Anthes migrate
my song for anthos I haven't done a lot
of thinking so this kind of mainstream
endgame by Taylor Swift I hope that
anthos is for our customers the end game
we want to be your end game we want to
be your a team living life in peace okay
we also are just to test whether you
read slides on our we you know we're
putting a little test who do you think
is missing state Jennifer is missing
answer you've seen her
you've seen her at a keynote today she
needs to go to last minute a press event
so we're gonna pretend to be her and so
questions for her here okay so after the
announcement this morning I walked
around Moscone Center can't believe how
many people there are today and asked
across people what are some of the
burning questions on their mind about
mentos and i compiled some of them so
we're gonna start from a few questions
from that list and then we will open up
to a live audience question so the very
first question everybody wants to know
why did we change the name from cloud
service platform to enzo's aparna what
do you think
okay so anthos is greek without services
platform is not greek a lot of the
components are you know named in greek
like kubernetes and it CEO and creative
so anthos is a more apropos name also
anthems means blue you know bringing
something to life and we believe that
anthos is a game changer it's something
that is bringing a change in the
tree that hasn't been there before
because it's removing the risk of being
multi-cloud and giving users choice so
that's why the name anthos for the
platform bringing life to multi-cloud
thank you okay then then now with all
the name then we wanted to talk about
what is the vision of pencils and why
our enterprises excited about it it's
been a phenomenal journey over the last
many years that we've been implementing
the vision of cloud and our customers
have been experimenting with lots of
technologies we have gone through many
iterations of application modernization
platform as a service and when we
launched kubernetes we struck a chord we
actually the industries and the signals
that is the model that work for us with
answers we are bringing is that
operational model we bring it everywhere
we are actually complementing within all
of other technologies such as they have
an end-to-end solutions that they can
start using to modernize and transform
their enterprises today that flexibility
is based on our open source investments
and that makes that platform open open
around everywhere and being able to
enable an open ecosystem of partners
that will help us they leave it all of
the technology that is needed for those
enterprises to be successful next have
we heard from any early customers out
how anthos improves their development
and release velocity yes actually we had
today in the spotlight session we had
two customers that's been using anthos
hsbc and la blaw and it's important to
say that ever since we have announced
CSP eight months ago we were mostly
focusing about working with our
customers and anthos is a platform a
product that puts users first anthos
gives customers choice so they want to
get the agility and velocity that the
cloud promised them to have but it also
introduced new risk for them for example
how do you manage those multiple
environments how do you verify and
approve new services meet the pas
minibar and your developers can use
how do we make sure that your talent is
not spread too thin so we heard today
for example from HSBC how they are
excited that Antos give them that
velocity both on Prem well they have
workers that are not intending to move
and they have regulation they want to
meet and on GCP that was one example
Hashim Hisham sorry from la blaw said
that autos helps him of course with
agility but he was focusing about how it
helps him to build the best team because
when we talk about digital
transformation it starts with the people
and by bringing anthos into your his
organization he can attract the best
talent by letting them developers use
the newest technologies out there he
gives developers the choice to use
whatever services they want and they can
really use and focus on bringing value
because they are using managed product
but those are just two examples of how
customers were excited about Antos okay
great thank you now they're excited
about it we know some of them also have
started testing sure so in the case of
HSBC they're looking to have a
centralized development environment
where all of their different lines of
business so it's a big bank it's a
global bank they've got like the retail
banking the commercial banking The
Wealth Management Group and they want to
have a centralized development platform
that's on Prem that all these groups can
basically develop on and like many banks
actually Scotia Bank is very similar
they want a separation of concerns
between what the developers access and
that layer should be something that's
really super simple fast for them to get
started and roll applications out versus
what the operators access and what the
operators access has to be something
where they're centralized control and
they can implement implement Enterprise
policies to make sure that you know all
their compliance and regulatory
requirements are met when you think
about the banks they have in the case of
HSBC they said forty thousand developers
you know so there's a variety of
different skill levels some of them are
are with the banks some of them are
contractors and so they want really a
simplified interface for development but
a very tight tightly controlled
environment for compliance and
regulatory and security and the reason
they want gke on-prem is so that they
have a consistent environment that when
they move to the cloud everything
they've built this cloud ready and they
can just move it to the cloud so that's
that's one example we had another
example of Kohl's Kohl's is a retailer
they have many many stores I think 1,800
or some stores and they want an
environment in each of those stores
that's kind of a compact environment but
has the compute that's required and they
can do you know continuous integration
continuous delivery from a centralized
cloud-based development platform and
then deliver to those retail locations
so those are two examples of anthos in
action and I can add about Cardinal
health that they've been trying out
Antos migrate and moving from VMs to
container so they've been migrating to
cloud and they were excited to actually
get the observability capabilities into
their environment so by moving from VMs
or a tree to kubernetes they already get
a better service operator experience
automatically great thank you
so when we think about these industries
whether it's you know banking or retail
or healthcare we know that security is
top of mind for far of these happenings
so Jeff why don't you tell us about how
we think about security in the hybrid
world okay so over the course of 2019 as
we look at this year we've sort of got
four main pillars of of work that we're
doing and they they tie in to the way
that anthos looks at the world so we
think of security of the cloud which are
all of the different security controls
that we build and all the compliance and
regulatory compliance that we do all of
the default encryption and
and and strong authentication on
connections you don't have to do
anything in order to get those things
then security in the cloud where we
provide you with all of the
configurations and options that you
create your own security sort of
settings and portfolios from those are
your your firewall settings or VPC
service controls for logical boundaries
I am an orc policies and then security
services so this year you'll see new
things from us on the services side
where we are building services on top of
those things and then our fourth goal is
around securing anthos so all of the
work that we're doing needs to be
portable to anthos so we are taking sort
of the best of gke security sto security
secure pipelines through GK's secure
connections and an envoy and
certificates through through sto and
leverage leveraging all of that through
anthos so we're securing the platform
itself on prem and as you migrate you
get all the benefits of the other pieces
in the cloud as well so it's a really
nice nice fit those security services
that i was talking about will announce a
bunch of those tomorrow and you'll see
us start to push those down towards
anthos as well over the course of this
year that's the that's a top benefit for
those even you know without moving your
workloads of Prem you can already start
to benefit from a lot of these security
value from Google ok cool another big
announcement from from anthos this
morning was our marketplace so Alberto
why don't you tell us what it means to
customers especially to enterprises I'm
super excited about the marketplace the
the reason being is because now that we
have a platform that'll work customers
can start investing and building their
applications they have the need to find
that existing that the way they manage
their existing solutions is very
important slab aureus as they were
building their own platform so we have
the opportunity to actually help our
partners bring coming to the platform
and meet the customer meet their
customers on the platform
and simplify the operational process the
procurement process such as all our
customers can't find all their
applications all the services that they
need at the click of a button and half
of the whole lifecycle and ensuring that
those services are delivered in a
consistent way one of the things that
what customers tell us is that yet great
we loved your platform but when
something goes wrong who who do I have
to talk to so a lot of investment is
going on to make sure that there is a
consistent way to deliver and run those
services in run flows such as our
customers have a consistent experience
and they can actually you know get spend
more time just building their
applications versus trying to figure out
what what throat to choke great thank
you
okay so I will wait a little bit to come
back to the Mosconi questions let's
let's come back to this room we can open
for live questions Lucy has the mic okay
so so last year GCP next rate the CSP
was announced right and as part of that
Jiki on-prem was part of that offering
and then and then managed this year was
one of them right and and now we have an
toes so has there been a change in
strategy from last year or is it just an
extension of yeah so no change in
strategy you know we've taken the NSO
the announcement from last year we've
taken it forward next step UK on Prem
what we announced as part of anthos is
now GA and we saw a tremendous demand
when we announced it last year I think
we mentioned in our spotlight we had
over a thousand customers sign up and so
we took that customer feedback we
actually worked directly with those
customers to bring the product through
alpha-beta and now announced GA here
today what we've done though in addition
is we've added several components into
the into the overall platform that is
anthos last year we also announced the
config management capability which is
from a single source of truth across all
your different environments and all your
different clusters you can deploy
policies our back policies quota
policies a number of different policies
that also moved to GA and last year was
when we announced the introduction of
the marketplace and as Alberto stated
that has also moved to GA so those three
components very tightly moved to GA as
part of anthos and of course the managed
is to your piece the manages to your
piece I think we previously announced
that it's beta in gke and we're moving
forward and over the course of our
roadmap this year we'll be bringing that
to the rest of anthos had one more
question about the Antos migrate right
so that's that's a new thing that there
was not something which was which was
there last year right and I think I
think you mentioned that there are some
customers who are already leveraging it
or use it using that right I'm just
trying to understand like is it because
we come from a legacy wall right and
we're migrating applications to the
cloud and how how easy in that case
would would Antos migrate B right
because you're dealing with monolith
application with different databases and
then we use managed services or manage
databases in the cloud right so in that
case
would an toast my grade be applicable or
or is it is it something where you
already build cloud native applications
and only then you can use it no actually
and those migrates and so it's one of
two new capabilities as part of anthos
this year so we talked about what moved
to GA which is the three or four
capabilities we talked about last year
and the two new capability is that we
introduced this year one is anthos
migrate which takes your monoliths
existing monoliths
including your databases some things
like Sybase you know your websphere we
showed you know a CRM application Sugar
CRM so very much
you know existing what you might call
packaged applications where you might
not even have the source code that's
what aunt those migrate targets and it
moves that as a system container into
gke and we announce that that capability
it's brand new it's something that I
think is kind of a first in the industry
particularly given the speed and the
simplicity of the migration so we showed
a demo in our spotlight where it was
less than five minutes of course we were
biting our nails and you know but we did
the migration right there on the stage
click that you know picked it off and
then and then completed it right there
on the stage and five minutes into a
system container bringing you the
benefits of the bin packing the benefits
of the isolation from the OS patching
and freedom from the VM and of course
bringing you into a tool chain where you
have su enabled manage dissed you
enabled in that GK environment so you
can view that's the RM system now still
a monolith as a service you know in
stackdriver and so forth and set
security policies so it brings it into
the anthos framework that's why it's
called anthos migrated and yet we do
that with zero code changes so not
breaking the monolith but I do want to
say that's the first step you know
that's just the first step you may want
to break the monolith ultimately
certainly the customers that I have that
are on Sybase they don't intend to be on
Sybase for ever you know they're
thinking of breaking it but this is a
good first step how easy is it to do you
know it's not that difficult it's
actually surprisingly easy it's based on
and
built on using the same technology that
you be used for VM to VM migration which
we acquired through a company called
Belle Estrada and so it's actually
fairly enterprise-ready
but there is setup involved you have to
set up the agent on in your vSphere
environment but it's actually quite rich
and we've got you know a handful of
customers that are doing this already we
mentioned Cardinal health we actually
mentioned a couple others on stage and
it's pretty versatile this is just the
beginning of our road map so you can
migrate from VMware on-prem you can also
migrated from VMs and AWS and in future
the destination we're gonna right now
it's just GK in the cloud but in the
future will also be GK on Prem so that's
the and and we'll continue adding
applications to it I would just like to
it just to complete the picture you as
well this is a change of strategy and we
talked about what was added this year
around anthos so we mentioned the anthos
migrate we also talked about the multi
cloud this time for the first time so
already lastly we talked about
connecting all your kubernetes
environment or GK environments from a
single control plane from a single pane
of glass and this year we are talking
about connecting any kubernetes cluster
into that environment and actually
applying similar policies and tools and
experience on that and the third thing
actually I will add two more things we
also did the cloud run so we demoed that
today right so everything we do here is
about engineering velocity they don't
really care about kubernetes so we are
helping customers with cloud run move
from a container image to a running
application internet-facing running
application in seconds okay it's that
easy and we also show that so that would
be the other thing that we have added
and the last thing which I'm very happy
which also parts of the marketplace and
so on is really the ecosystem that is
built on top of anthos right so TK today
in his keynote spend much of his time
talking about the partnerships if it's
hardware software you know you social
you saw their system integrators and
eius be really having that support and
community in delivering anthos so
we'll be the complete new things in
antis but this is really the next step
as we see it in the journey in
modernization either corner from Jim Oh
see I was touching a couple of things
breaking up the monolith multi-cloud the
question I was talking to Lucy about
this earlier the the anthos thing looks
very cool but it seems to assume that
that your application runs completely
and entirely inside kubernetes what if
you try to make use of the cloud native
services like pub/sub or you know even
Amazon queuing services so do you guys
have any plans for anthos to support
things outside of kubernetes I'm not
sure that makes sense absolutely so
things that are coming throughout the
year we have very rich roadmap of
capabilities that are becoming part of
anthers throughout the year and we have
talked many sessions around our sto
technology and service mass and one of
our goals is making sure that whatever
the workload is running we gives you the
capabilities to manage how any workload
whatever they are and what how it is
implemented
how we can actually help you manage the
data plane between VM and container ABM
ABM VM and a service a container for all
the permutations effectively gives you
the same policy system that we are
implementing today to manage effectively
contour ice workloads we will give you
the same capabilities to manage the data
plane and therefore connecting and
modernizing the way all applications
that you are running whatever they're
running how it'll have been implemented
will give you those capabilities so
that's one of the the investments that
we are doing and we will ship it wow did
you hear anything else that you guys
want to add
great so there's many levels of how we
we are enabling managed services one of
the principles that we are applying to
anthers is that when we think about the
services that we bring into anthers is
that we're gonna treat first party and
third party service is the same we we
want to give you exactly the same
consistency that we are bringing into
the platform with first party services
we want to bring the same consistency to
third party services and we will our
goal is to make sure that whatever
services that we bring into anthers work
everywhere will you want answers to run
that is that is one of our goals and the
journey just started one of the things
that we announced we are now seeing
throughout next is the kubernetes
marketplace and all the ponies that we
have any combination marketplace but
also some things that are truly nerdy
for example Palo Alto Networks have
actually shaped as part of the company's
marketplace the capability of
integrating the threat detection
appliance with one click of a button so
you have a community environment you
deploy these adaptor and that connects
to threat detection appliances your
anthos service mess such as you get all
of that capability without having to
change any code and will see that there
is a lot of services that we are gonna
we're going to bring into answers that
are gonna give you all the capabilities
that you need to be able not just to
modernize your application but also
integrate with existing applications may
be a related question to that as well so
I work in the bi space and in the bi
space you have everything from data
storage ETL data warehouse semantic
models and then and then you have your
visualizations I don't see how anthos
can help migrate that if it can will be
great because one of the things is that
Google is not available in China so if
we are able to migrate a workload that
Google to another cloud that is
available China as is that would be
great but I I'm so having a hard time
understanding how and those will help in
this particular situation so Anthes not
a platform that needs to be in Google
cloud so for example when we talk to
HSBC they are running in regions where
Google cloud is not available
application because the word application
to me well the way it's being used is
use of front-end applications I can see
that but when you have an ecosystem of
components that forms a data warehouse
application how is that so it's not
necessarily meant to be migrated it sort
of depends on whether the customer
wishes to migrate their data warehouse
including all parts of the data
warehouse so I'm not sure if I'm
necessarily answering your question but
the example that I would give of a
regulated company which is HSBC is that
they're running in environments where
there's no cloud available for example
they're in Saudi Arabia and they're in
certain China is similar and they have
data that they need to keep on Prem
for regulatory reasons they're not
moving that to the cloud and so the
benefits of actually the on Prem
component of anthos which is GK on Prem
the reason that they're using it is
because it gives them a consistent
environment it's not in the cloud but
it's an environment that's that's that's
what we that's why we say bringing the
cloud to you because we're bringing the
cloud to your on-prem environment and
you run it the same way that you would
run it in the cloud your data warehouse
may or may not be running in kubernetes
your data warehouse may be running is
running outside right it's running
outside but it can still use the
capabilities of service management and
of policy management as long as you can
expose your your application your
various parts of your data warehouse
application as
services and so the initial kiss money
he talked about this in the spotlight he
said that he wants everything in his
environment to be his service he wants
the data that is on Prem to be front
ended by a service that can be accessed
through a set of API s and that is
something that he wants to manage as a
standard in in his on Prem as well as in
the cloud so that's the that's the way
at least in the anthos philosophy that
we would manage and on from these I
think I understood a nuance of the
question which I hinted it before is
that before anthology was used to be
called cloud services platform and the
actual name means that we wanted is a
platform services and we are working
with our customers and we are listening
to you and we are going to bring
whatever services that we need to be
into anthos whether it's first part of a
third party to make sure that interest
is you address your needs today we are
setting up just the the foundation of
that platform but we are working very
closely with our customers to understand
not just that you need the capabilities
to run your applications on the platform
but what services did you need to be
available on the platform I'm excited
because the over part third-party
partners can actually get there very
fast working with them to bring a lot of
those services there and but if there is
of course we are working with our
customers and figure out is their first
party services that you want to see on
that platform and having that
conversation to make sure that at some
point you have all that you need and and
probably something that you've also
everything about you don't want to
containerize or migrate everything like
that you can actually move to a managed
product right so we have our own data
warehouse services we've just acquired
Illuma which also helps migrating ok so
I'm not saying that that's the things
that write this on top of that we're
also moving services to the cloud so I'm
actually working with a number of
streamers will need to run potentially
other public clouds in environments
where you no good and I have a data
center and when we talk to them about
how do you make your workloads portable
between multiple clouds right like the
only obvious solution is going with you
know whether it's in computer are you
being storage in other places going with
open source standards right so the using
open source standards for workloads and
they're using a managed to control plane
and as our producer Khan was starting I
think from compute workloads and API
management policy management that kind
of definitely understand the it takes a
much larger stack for each application
and some of these early customers are
starting to use kind of the you know the
well-known kind of open source storage
and database products and we're looking
at more and more to make that manage the
experience easier for you to run
multiple clouds
okay that might have answered my
question but my company doesn't
manufacturing in China and we'd like to
have a point of presence there but so
far because we run everything on Google
cloud we haven't been able to and I
guess
are there any partners they have managed
to use ant those to sort of form a to
create like that point of presence in
say like on the factory floor for this
kind of purpose and how easy is it
specifically for China why don't we
connect offline we're not yet ready to
announce but we are looking at some of
these kind of you know special region
use cases
let's talk offline hi quick question and
so it's not actually more suggested than
anything but maybe you want to hear so
you really really helpful for moving VM
to kubernetes that's great but I already
bought OpenShift I'm running this
environment there can you help me
migrate it same thing that I will ask on
any other kubernetes that I'm open
source using I think that would be your
judge by for you guys specifically
consider the market we is the foundation
for a lot of these platforms and we're
working with were
partners to figure out what is the
things that what customers need to be
successful so of course that's our focus
making customers successful yes and I
would say that the key thing here is
talking about the experience but because
we do have the portability of walk
between those environments so that
actually already exists and what usually
users will appreciate that experience
and the ecosystem so that depends really
on what the customer in openshift there
is more than just a regular vanilla
kubernetes right I mean to be very
helpful if you will be helpful to do all
this data configuration I already
configure in this environment I help me
to move it yeah so definitely actually I
would say that the challenge of
migrating from a VM to gke is a bigger
challenge than moving from openshift to
anthos er gke it's actually much easier
because it is you know you already have
a set of amyl and there's only a couple
of objects in OpenShift that are
different there's a different CLI you
can essentially do the migration without
any sort of tooling this is not that
complicated and mentioned our multi
cluster capability our multi cluster
multi-cloud registration capability so
currently that is for a number of
different conformant distributions of
kubernetes I think we will work to bring
openshift in to that so you can have an
open shift cluster and educate you on
pram cluster and a cop's cluster in AWS
or wherever it is that you want and view
all of your workloads and all of your
resources from a single place and also
to deploy workloads across those
clusters so in that sense we'd like to
be able to would like users to be able
to manage their kubernetes environments
the same if there's a migration from
OpenShift
to gke I don't think that's that that's
that complicated but perhaps your
question was about the experience the
developer experience because there is a
paths essentially right that's built on
top of kubernetes in the case of
openshift
and anthos is a lot more modular
in that sense so there is the there is
the cluster cluster management Multi
cluster management layer there is also
an additional what we call module which
has the developer experience and that
developer experience is essentially
cloud run I don't know if you've tried
it it's extremely simple and it is based
underneath on K native it's a hosted
offering of K native and so it has
automated serving capabilities that I
mean for a developer are you can
essentially go from your source code or
a container in a registry and within
less than a minute so in seconds you
have an externally exposed endpoint that
is your application and it is
automatically scaled you don't have to
know what a deployment is you don't have
to know the services to set up any kind
of ingress you don't even have to know
about the cluster right that can all be
done for you by some central admin so
with cloud run and and that's really I
think it's it's a pass essentially with
cloud run you you get all of that set up
and as you get more traffic we
automatically the system automatically
scales the pods scales the scales the
cluster both up and down so all of that
is is what is the anthos developer
experience so my question is a is
probably a little bit confusing and
that's where the ethos of the question
is and let me try to leave a story and
I'll try to bring it together in the
question so be in middle management have
to work with the engineering teams the
developers and you answered a part of my
question over there with cloud run right
that how it can be right once and use
many times or write one and run many
times right but then when we have to
make a case to senior management or the
finance team when they're actually
signing the bill what's the value prop
with all these services what's the value
prop that
Anthes why why should we go from just a
compute engine where we are not running
our workloads in the cloud we did
convince them about kubernetes we did
convince them about a managed you know
offering but but then what's the value
prop with all these services and with
what is it going to cost us versus
having our own developers spend some
time you know building and managing
things on top of computer because you
know I'll borrow from what my friend
said we are we are still a legacy
company cloud development has a lot of
velocity right I mean even before we can
keep up with that new abilities come up
new facilities come up there are new
marketplaces which come up so so my my
point is while you know a part of it was
already answered with cloud run what's
the value prop in these services that we
can we can invite them in our workflow
or we can think about you know moving to
them in the future
so does that help and I'm sorry you know
like if it's yeah if it's confusing but
but that's as I said it's a it's also
where we are in middle management okay I
think several of us will probably want
to answer this question let me just give
a brief answer you know from the CIOs
perspective the top line about anthos is
that it minimizes or removes the risk of
lock-in and it maximizes your choice it
gives you the choice to deploy anywhere
and that's great when you but when you
bring it down you know the piece that
you don't have so you mentioned you you
know you've got this running in the
environment running already piece that
you don't have there are several pieces
but one of the pieces is you don't have
a multi cluster management capability
that's something that's unique in anthos
and it spans multiple clouds for
workload management you don't really
have the centralized policy and security
control and that's extremely important
for enterprises
right and then of course that separation
of concerns between developers giving
them you know an easy workflow where
they don't have to know
details and then giving the operators
all of the power to control things at
scale in a standard way
so I think that's the that's what I
would say to the CIO of course it comes
down to you know what
what is the TCO of doing it this way
versus doing it sort of ad-hoc one by
one in every environment managing
security policies separately and having
that fragmented estate and that has
people cost it has platform cost
it adds risk
yeah yeah so I mean we we have several
such customers and they're not
necessarily using all parts of the
platform but one that is and I don't
know that I can name them but it's a
retailer and they're using gke in the
cloud and like I said they have almost
you know a thousand stores and they want
to be able to run the same platform and
they've tried many different things you
know they've tried a lot of the existing
technologies but the multi cluster
management capability the ability to
distribute workloads from a single
source and to be able to manage policy
from a single source that's very
attractive and that's what they're
they're like you know I like GK in the
cloud it's fully managed I want that
capability in my stores and if you give
me workload management on top that's
awesome and we are actually working on a
set of white papers on TCO with example
so to quantify these values what's
easier to tell your CIO
and yeah and specifically talking about
I think I know which customer so they've
been they had to do it himself right so
they've wasted their talent on a problem
that we can solve for them all right so
that's actually clear they say okay
we're gonna get that to be more secured
and we can innovate more the TCO as a
preview what is in there you think about
it you have to run deploy and manage
your own kubernetes cluster starting
then you has to start adding in employee
proxies or orchestration making sure
that all the upgrades code is smooth if
you start adding all of the employee
cost time of line that you need most
customers take their cluster offline to
upgrade them so all of that is that hard
enough and you will see that the value
proposition that we bring with answers
is very compelling that's in the short
term that just immediately you can
calculate it there is an intangible
benefit that is that we're trying to
drive with anthers which is also the
standardization if you think about it
everybody's running the cover letters in
a different way
which means that it makes it impossible
for service provider to deliver services
on your platform because they don't know
how you run it they don't know which
components you're using which versions
or how they've been configured so an
intangible value of anthos it is a
platform that is common that means that
it's gonna unlock the opportunity to
have service providers deliver the
services they need as we were discussing
before whatever the first party of their
party so there is the short term total
cost of ownership but also strategically
do you want invest on a platform that is
gonna have an ecosystem around it one
more small thing as part of that that
process that you're talking about one of
those components that I see a lot are
our security and compliance and I'm
thinking of a meeting that a partner and
I were in about a week ago
where a large financial services firm
looking at that type of TCO there's the
above the line TCO where you're gonna
you know you're gonna save money you're
gonna make money etc but there's the
below the line where you're gonna save
time and all of that energy and effort
and you got to go through for every
application that you want to migrate
you've got to go through and you have to
justify the migration plan out the
migration you've got to assess all of
the security and then you have to assess
the compliance underneath that to to
make sure that you're not going to
completely blow up your compliance state
when you migrate so if we can
standardize all of that on anthos then
we can really streamline a big chunk of
that process for the customer
yeah so regarding Anton's migration any
plans for bare-metal migration yeah
it's part of moving to take the center
to the cloud you mean migration or by
migration from bare metal from right now
we're very focused on migrating existing
applications from virtual machines to
gke obviously to GCE and to GK on-prem
and so that's kind of the roadmap for
now because the way I'm seeing it we
have a lot of customers legacy customers
who are using you know all the legacy
data centers which which has application
development
real bare metal servers right it servers
each server which has its own
application and stuff like that a lot of
customers who are not using virtual
machines and stuff like that and I
believe that it would be helpful for
them if you would be able to provide
them with an agent that would be able to
migrate them into endows that would be
you know as far as I see it a valid use
case to move to communities and stuff
like that easier easily
so I think I want to take this a little
bit different you know part of this
vision for anthos and the service mesh
and bringing in the marketplace it
really seems like relies on Identity and
Access Management I mean it can I really
want to hear more about what what Google
is doing to you know plug in our
existing Identity and Access Management
environments and systems you know into
into the service mesh because you know
that's I don't want to have to reinvent
it for anthos because we already have it
right we're also a G suite school so we
also have it in Google already so
there's Identity and Access Management
kind of talked about both of them right
in terms of identity you know some of
the most important changes coming from
service matches in the past two we are
used service accounts right now you copy
P put in a github and you know how
Britax lose and then really service ID
is as we see the future of the identity
for services right so you know we are
more and more kind of looking at best
practice based on service identities and
moremore gonna hide try to hide service
account as an implementation detail
really think about it as a strong
identity of services and try to you know
make you do as little of the copying
keys as possible eventually you should
forget about keys with strong way out to
authenticate your services and that's a
much safer way to express your policies
and then in terms of kind of user
identity right weight would kind of and
those allow stress to think about not
only your in passes sure employees
identity you know you use cloud identity
you do a federation so our but always GK
and Prem now we're building kind of no
connections integrations with your
existing on Prem IDP such as Active
Directory but we also now thinking about
you serving your customers so that the
new identity platform you know we're
launching is about how do you kind of
provide an identity service for your
applications customers kind of extending
and you know beyond just your developers
but to your customers as well and in
terms of access management you know
there are GCP has its own kind of
policies NATO policy for the
infrastructures and then with you know
communities sto they also come with the
canary style API and are back and the
kubernetes style of policies right now I
think with you know CSP config
management we help you distribute those
consistently across all your clusters
and measures we are kind of looking into
you know what would it take for this is
a kind of this is a common problem right
so today we have it between the new
kubernetes system and GPI yeah but you
also have that with sequel you also have
that with Linux
when is I'm hold down in the past is
we've created a bridge between your G
cpi-m system and the Linux permission
system right so you have this user login
feature we're looking at additional
opportunities where you have pain points
managing across multiple these am
systems we are looking how to build as
bridges for you and those is really
optimized for hybrid and multi cloud and
so the configuration and policy
management in anthos is very much based
on kubernetes are back in quota
management and is geo configuration and
managing that from a centralized source
of truth I think the question perhaps is
you know can that centralized source of
truth be I am GCP I am for example can
this source of truth eat the IM system
that we already have yeah potentially
extending the GCP I am you know
great but I really don't want three
different systems so certainly I mean as
ray mentioned we are doing identity
Federation with Active Directory so that
yes and we're looking for ways to you
know through kubernetes is do we learned
the only way to really have consistency
across not a cloud is to have them you
know attached to an open standard
right so we're looking at what are the
abstract concepts that are not provided
specific that we can leverage for
example namespace is a great concept
right service identity is another so
we're looking at how to evolve kind of
both you know G cpi-m as well as our
back policies with the community kind of
towards
an abstraction layer that can live I can
you know on top of multiple different
platforms I
how will it be licensed how am I gonna
buy this the licensing is it's a
subscription license that is based on a
pervy CPU a pervy CPU managed by the
platform as calculated by kubernetes
metering so that's the that's the model
and it's in blocks of a hundred B CPUs
so we expect users will want to purchase
several blocks of 100 B CPUs billed
monthly but you know sign in signing up
for a subscription for say a year thank
you we're almost at time and I wonder if
each of the panelists would say oh ok
since this is an AMA I have to ask one
horse-sized duck or 100 duck sized
horses which would you rather fight it's
definitely it's it's got to be the duck
sized horses because the horse sized
duck is just way too dangerous
one big individual or side that yeah
we're micro-services we don't like the
one monolithic thing my final question
for the panelists is if there's one talk
that does not already happen is there
something that you would like to share
and ask people to check it out for the
rest of the the next conference so I
think on Thursday I don't remember the
exact time but on Thursday sometime in
the afternoon there's a talk on
connecting many clusters to two anthos I
would recommend that talk the authors
are the presenters are Matt DeLeo
and I think Ian chakras but Matt DeLeo
Matthew DeLeo if you look that up
hey I'm talking tomorrow if you guys are
free security spotlight I don't remember
when is the time but I think what we
hear many people talk about in the
context of anthos is governance so there
is a session with John on Antos config
management I can check that but
definitely just look and look for a
Antos config management session there's
a couple of sessions around the service
match I'm very excited about things that
we are showing to help modernize the
data plane and so these sessions from
dancer-ly and David Monroe they are both
extremely interesting I recommend those
and Ray do you have a yeah I don't
remember the exact time we have a
session security best practice for
hybrid that's a joint session between an
engineer from recalling from and those
config management and koban who's a
product manager from networking so these
two you know configure networking
together so shipping a security problems
yep excellent so thank you all for being
here and thank you Pamela swear for
forgiving this time thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]